the california recall election is just
12 days from today and to be clear the
opposition to gavin newsom as governor
is bipartisan now the leading candidate
to replace newsome is larry elder and
he's just picked up a major endorsement
from gloria romero glory romero is the
former democratic majority leader of the
california state senate which is a big
deal in the state of california gloria
romero joins us tonight thanks so much
for coming on i appreciate it kind of
amazing to read thank you for having me
oh absolutely your background that
you're endorsing larry elder an
alternative to the to the governor the
democratic governor why are you doing
this
really two major reasons the first one
was that i was just tired of the false
narrative that was put forward that this
is a right wing conspiracy there were
1.7 million californians that signed
that recall petition i was one of them
so i wanted to publicly assert that this
is widespread democrats independents
green republican across the board and
the second major reason really that i uh
decided to endorse especially larry
elder was that i was tired of the rules
for thee but not for me attitude of the
prince of the french laundry who shut
down our public schools but then he sent
his kids to school and it's one where i
looked at larry's record and believed
that he's our best option to really
break the monopoly of special interests
when it comes to education and to offer
especially latino and african-american
families in california school choice
options so those are the two major
reasons but there are many that i could
list boy those are great reasons i mean
california i can say having grown up
there had the best schools in the
country they were famously good and now
it has among the lowest performing i
mean you've been there i think your
whole life
how upsetting is that to people
um it's very upsetting and when we take
a look at even some polling that's going
forward 54 percent of latinos
are in support of the recall overall
especially latino and african-american
families
favor school choice
so this is one where if we look at the
statistics today we find that about 70
percent of latino children are not even
at proficiency levels when it comes to
math and that's about 80 percent for
african american kids but because of the
um the way in which the schools are run
even even when the state identifies the
school as chronically underperforming
kids can't get out you're zip coded
there and so
you know in looking at it the the
powerful monopoly of the california
teachers association which is a major
endorser of the democratic party and of
course gavin it blocks any type of
reform
you are telling the truth i think even
people who have no familiarity with
california state politics or its school
system can tell from what you just said
that that is absolutely right and the
state needs a change and i think you are
very brave for coming forward and doing
this thank you for joining us gloria
romero good luck in 12 days hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else